Thank You Jeanette I want to just run
through some slide
quickly just a few minutes to tell you a
little bit about the research in a way
to answer this question why is
complicated reason important and also
why this is a center important this is
begin with what I'm calling the critical
perspective this was actually an earlier
view about bereavement and complicated
grief and actually one I endorse this is
a quote from a paper I wrote in 2001
with Stacy Coleman in which we were
arguing that it wasn't really necessary
to have a particular diagnosis for grief
and I'll read this to you according to
the DSM for bereavement is a stressor
event that warrants a clinical diagnosis
only in extreme cases when other DSM
categories of psychopathology like major
depression or PTSD are evident in this
article the article that this came from
we review empirical evidence on the
longitudinal course phenomenological
features and possible diagnostic
relevance of grief reactions then we
concluded that the evidence was
generally consistent with the view with
the DSM's view of bereavement and that
individuals showing chronic grief
reactions could be relatively easily
accommodated by existing diagnostic
categories major depression or PTSD and
that's really I think an opinion I held
at the time pretty clearly I thought
well that's makes sense to me but
unfortunately it didn't unfortunately I
said should say it didn't really hold up
for example a number of reviews began to
appear showing that grief treatments
were generally not effective and one of
these appeared after another in quick
succession and that really got a lot of
attention if one review appears says
grief treatments are not effective in
academic community though the mental
health community will wonder about it
but one after another was saying it's
really not effective and one of the
reasons seem that they really weren't
the right treatments they were not
targeting grief symptoms they were
targeting either depression or PTSD so I
was at a number of panels and we really
began to think about this so we decided
to ask the question empirically our
grief symptoms clinically relevant is
there more
to grieve than depression and PTSD and
in the language the research language we
would say this grief have incremental
validity if we have depression
and we have PTSD trauma reactions do we
need anything more do we need something
called grief to explain those things so
we came up with a number of different
studies this is the design of one so it
soon after the loss a few months after
the loss we had people go through a
structured interview we measure
depression we measure PTSD symptoms
trauma symptoms and grief symptoms then
we had people rated independently by
clinicians for the functioning we did
that again in another interview we had
their friends rate how well they were
doing we looked at their heart rate
responsility when they talked about the
loss etc nobody repeated this again a
little over a year later so we had lots
of different measures this was actually
a fairly rigorous way to test this so
does grief symptoms to the idea of grief
bias anything well the answer was
resounding yes yes yes yes yes and all
fronts and this was as I said a fairly
rigorous test so we found that grief
symptoms predicted current and future
adjustment the predicted heart rate
response they predicted what their how
the friends thought people were doing
over and above depression of PTSD this
is really strong evidence and I was kind
of amazed by this it really said wow
there was something that's in grief that
is not in these other disorders so we
did it in another study we found the
same thing in another study with a new
sample different measures you know we
really tried to do this as
scientifically rigorously as we could
and we found again the same thing the
other thing that emerged so we know
there's something unique about grief
that's not depression in PTSD the other
thing that was beginning emerges that
treatments were actually more effective
when they were targeting grief symptoms
and targeting prolongs grief giving
people some time to get a better on
their own and then finding out who was
not functioning well and dr. shear did a
study of 2005 in JAMA published in JAMA
that really was the first major study
that targeted bereavement grief symptoms
specifically with the treatment designed
for that and this was really big news
because it said alright there is
something we can get it we can help
people by specifically targeting grief
so in a lot of the research I do is
Janette mentioned we study resilience we
studied other prototypical trajectories
we follow people over time large groups
of people and map their outcomes and
we've
this was war we've done this with all
kinds of ents and a lot of this research
with bereavement so we have these
different patterns of outcome that we
can match some people are resilient some
people recover some people show more
complicated reactions here's an example
of one of those studies published in
2002 this was a large population sample
that we followed for about seven years
and we had measures before and after
this is depression but we also did this
with grief symptoms and you can see
there is a group there that just doesn't
get any better they're not they're doing
fine before the loss then they they they
get worse and they they're not able to
get better so we have these kinds of
patterns then the question becomes so
what's going on what causes these
different groups to to branch out like
this why doesn't everybody get better
the same way and this is why a center
like this is so important because we can
begin to try to answer that question so
everybody's trying to adapt to loss and
some people are doing it better than
others so we've been looking at emotion
regulation something we call emotion
regulation flexibility this is a project
we're doing in my lab across the street
there are lots of streets that people
talk about being across that we're
talking about that one over there and
we're doing part of this in
collaboration with dr. Sheeran
intervention studies and we're doing it
also in many other ways it's based on
the idea that at adapting to these
aversive life events requires
flexibility this is a an emergent idea
and we've identified three components of
flexibility being sensitive to context
having a repertoire of responses and
being able to monitor feedback and this
is the same thing as what I just
described I'll show you graphically so
we have a stressor event in this case a
loss there's impinges upon us something
happens to us and we are now thrown off
for disequilibrium so we have to
appraise what this means what is this
demanding of us what do we have to do to
recover from this event and people vary
and how well they can do this so we call
this context sensitivity then after
people make those appraisals they have
to enact a strategy they have to decide
how they're going to respond to this
kind of event and people vary in their
ability to do that as well so we call
this repertoire some people have a much
more elaborate repertoire
of coping responses and others some
people you know sometimes we need to
express emotions sometimes we need to
suppress emotion or talk or not talk or
seek help or not seek help or just grin
and bear it whatever the situation might
recover and then once we enact a
strategy we need to monitor it we need
to just find out how is this working is
this doing what we hoped it would do and
should we maintain the strategy adapt
adjust it try something new et cetera
and we do this in a long-term event like
bereavement we do this over and over and
over we repeat this cycle many times so
what we found in our laboratory research
early on people who are not as sensitive
to the context and we can measure this
experimentally are more likely to show
that complicated grief pattern whereas
people who are more sensitive or more
likely to recover and then later on
we're finding that people who already
have developed complicated grief who are
who lack a repertoire of coping
responses those are the people that will
continue to suffer so this is just the
beginning of this kind of research it
took 10 years to do it but it's just the
beginning and there's a lot of work that
can be done so this this kind of work
which I'm going through very quickly
just to give you a flavor of it is why
this kind of center is so important
because we can do this kind of basic
research there's intervention happening
in an ongoing way and we can interface
we can reach out to the community and
there's that kind of collaboration and
those things bring bringing those things
together in one place is so important
because this is a big public health
problem people are resilient and I'm
have said this many times but not
everybody is resilient and people need
help when they need help they need help
and we really need to understand why why
certain courses are followed and what we
can do about it so this Center I think
is really important in that regard thank
you